Hey youtubers it's Charlie and the CW just
confirmed that Arrow Season 3 and The Flash
will both premiere the second week in October,
they basically announced when everything is
starting including Supernatural and all their
other shows.
So I'm going to do a breakdown of some important
dates as well as an update on what's going
on this week.
That includes a couple of special giveaways.
There is a lot of stuff coming.
Hello to all you new people.
Since it's the summer right now I'm doing
weekly bonus videos for Marvel and DC movies
and tv shows.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Guardians of the Galaxy is out next Tuesday,
so I'll be doing a bunch of stuff for that.
First let's talk about Arrow Season 3 and
The Flash.
They're going to be on different days, so
I'm super happy.
It'll just make it easier for me to do videos
for both of them.
The Flash is coming first on Tuesday October
7th at 8PM Eastern Time.
It's going to be every week at that time.
Arrow is going to be just like Season 2.
It's starting on Wednesday Oct 8th at 8PM
Eastern Time and all the rest of the episodes
will be at the same time.
There will be 23 episodes just like last season.
They haven't officially picked up the Flash
for a full season yet.
Usually it only takes a couple weeks after
a new show starts airing before they say yes
or no to a full season.
So we'll know what's going on with The Flash
before November.
Just to give you an idea of what's going on
with The Flash at the CW with all the suits
and business people.
Things are really good, of all the new shows
that the CW is making this year like iZombie
and Jane the Virgin, The Flash is their favorite.
The one they're holding up as most important.
Which means they like it so much the odds
of a full season are really good.
The way they're airing the first two episodes
is kind of weird too.
So normally on Wednesday nights, The 100 will
air after Arrow.
But for the first two weeks of Arrow Season
3, October 8th and October 15th, instead of
airing The 100, they're re-airing the first
two episodes of The Flash.
So they're showing the first two episodes
of The Flash twice, because remember it's
a Tuesday show.
It just means they really really want you
to watch it.
And you should because it's awesome.
I just did a video about the pilot episode
that leaked.
That's going to be the first episode even
though they'll probably post it online so
people can stream it.
If you did watch that please use spoiler tags
when talking about it in the comments.
I know a lot of you guys also keep asking
me about Supernatural.
I will be doing Season 10 videos.
There were a few weeks this past year that
I had to skip since I still have a full time
job.
It's premiering right after The Flash, it's
going to be every Tuesday night at 9PM Eastern
just like it always has been.
If you're an international person and you've
been watching Arrow, The Flash will air on
the same channel, just a day before.
I know the day changes depending on which
country you live in.
Like I watch Arrow on Wednesdays, but people
in the UK watch it at a much later date.
Other really important Arrow and Flash Dates.
At Comic Con this year, they'll be doing back
to back panels, Comic Con is going to start
Thursday July 24th and end Sunday July 27th.
It's going to be just like the panel Arrow
did last year.
Since Comic Con is such a bigger deal than
most other conventions they'll probably be
screening footage from both shows.
And there should be a special screening of
the Pilot Episode one of those nights if they
don't do it during the actual panels.
It's about 42 minutes long and Comic Con Panels
are usually only one hour long.
I'll be making a few Comic Con Preview videos
next month that will explain everything way
better.
Other big DC Comics TV Shows, a lot of you
have asked me about Constantine on NBC and
Gotham on FOX.
Yes I will be making weekly videos for both
those shows.
Constantine Episode 1 is on Friday October
24th at 10PM Eastern Time, it's going to be
a Friday show like Grimm.
And Gotham doesn't have an official premiere
date yet, but it's going to be a Monday show
at 8PM Eastern Time.
It's going to lead into Sleepy Hollow.
They did say Sleepy Hollow will come back
on September 22nd, so maybe Gotham will start
around then.
All of the comic book shows are premiering
around the same time.
I sold my soul to the devil and got all of
the networks to agree to air everything on
different days.
Now I just have to try and get my soul back...
Seriously though this is what it's going to
look like Mondays will be Gotham, Tuesdays
The Flash and Supernatural, Wednesdays Arrow,
Thursdays I get a night off.
I'll still be posting videos that night, but
I'm not doing any Thursday shows.
Fridays are Constantine, Saturdays are Doctor
Who and Sundays are Walking Dead.
That also doesn't include any bonus videos
I'll be doing like Game of Thrones.
It's just that for a giant chunk of the fall.
All those shows will be on at the same time.
Which means I won't be sleeping a lot.
But it's going to be so much fun.
I'll be doing bonus videos for a lot of this
stuff during the Summer so as long as you
guys are current on all the videos I'm posting
you'll know what's going on and when stuff
is starting.
The rest of this week is going to be a little
crazy.
I'm going to VidCon tomorrow through Saturday
and Legend of Korra Book 3 is premiering the
first 3 episodes Friday Night starting at
8PM Pacific Time.
That's on Nickelodeon in the United States.
They post the episodes the next day on their
website, so if you are an international person,
you can watch them Saturday or Sunday, depending
on which time zone you live in.
I'm going to be posting a bonus Korra video
Friday Morning so I'll explain all that again.
To anybody who will also be at VidCon this
weekend and want to meet me in person or say
hi, please let me know either on this video
or on my Facebook page or on Twitter.
There's links for all that in the description.
If there are enough people I'll arrange a
meetup and if only a couple of you are there
I'll arrange for us to high five as we walk
past each other in the hallway.
I'm going to post a personal Q&A, so if you
ever wanted to ask me questions about me you
can do so on this video or on facebook or
twitter or any of the other videos I do this
week.
That video will probably post on Saturday
or Sunday.
So last thing, giveaways.
You should all know about the weekly Game
of Thrones giveaway I'm doing this summer,
I'm giving away one Song of Ice and Fire book
to a random subscriber in the comments on
my Game of Thrones bonus videos.
The first winner will be announced this Sunday
during my next Game of Thrones video.
My Legend of Korra Giveaway starts on Friday,
same deal except the prize for that is an
Amazon gift card.
That will run all season for all the episodes.
The special giveaways aside from those are
Comic Con and then I'll be doing a separate
giveaway when all the comic book shows come
back in the fall.
The Comic Con giveaway won't start till Comic
Con starts, but for every show I do that's
at Comic Con, I'm going to be giving away
one figure or gift card per day.
I haven't quite decided what the prize will
be, it will be worth at least 20 dollars.
So if I do videos for like 10 shows and they're
all at Comic Con, it means I'm giving away
10 prizes.
All of the prizes will be themed based on
the shows, but the value for each will be
the same.
Then when everything gets ready to premiere
in the fall.
I'm going to do the same thing.
Just one prize for each show.
As always, all the giveaways are open to international
people.
Whenever we get closer to those special giveaways
I'll remind everyone.
So don't worry.
Right now click here to learn all about the
leaked episode of The Flash and click here
to learn all about the Batman Villains coming
to the Gotham show.
Thanks for watching, see you guys at VidCon,
high fives!